I have not seen you since we taped this
video together that went viral the lift
remote no and this is the first time
that you and I are seeing each other
since it was it was you me you yeah ice
cube you myself like we got a calling
ice cube oh no no no no cuz I can't call
him yes thank you
me you are cute there might be other
cubes out there too what does it a
bouillon cube or oh it's just cute cuz
well I don't know there could be
different q oh I'm doing IP pause gotta
go first and last does that don't both
Ice Cube not come cube you know from now
on i conk you and then call me call me
little kiss who can look at who else in
listen that that lift remote that thing
blew up and what was this secret we just
had to seem to have him great chemistry
well first of all uh Conan I I have to
say this uh the secret was you meant
that video was funny because of you man
cube were ourselves but putting you in
that environment you know I don't know
if you guys seen in video night they
went viral but we basically took Conan
all over I mean we took him to some
pretty bad spots and and to see Conan
all I remember is you at Wendy's and I
remember us ordering and man cubes order
was so simple I asked I said yo give me
that spicy chicken and cube said yeah
I'm gonna go with that Baconator and you
said I want I want a sandwich but can
you guys give me the Asiago bun I'll
never forget I'll never forget how
complicated his order was at Wendy's and
me and King Willie look there's like
this might be the whitest [ __ ]
[Applause]
they're so bad
the weight is meted out now then the
movie the movie comes out and it breaks
all kinds of record off takes off yeah
everybody have you seen ride-along Thank
You Man movie broke records on yeah now
here's my question no I know there's
going to be a ride-along to the natural
question that I would have is is there a
part for me well don't laugh at that
that undermines my authority in this
negotiation the laugh definitely made me
not take you as seriously no but but
honam listen look at me me in the movie
coming in listen we owe a lot of that
success to you yes I think there is a
part for you man I don't see why there
can't be yeah white God number one okay
no my god number one there get to be
number one [ __ ] no you don't even
know what a bad I want to be son I want
to be Street white mouth like I'm a
bunch of P Street you can't even say
that without lad no okay white God
number one can be Street
my god listen okay this scene
yeah you do a scene where I come in and
I gotta talk to white God number one
uh-huh you know I say something like hey
did you see what that guy went and
you're like that way
cut you're done that's it so I guess
that's it one line that way that way
let's try it let's try so right now I
got number one okay right ready action
hey real quick do you see me I got with
the hood on it that way
[Applause]
oh my god that's a good move mark the
way you pointed yeah oh my god that
myself God look back through me they
just came up with that that listen
that's improv League at its best
yes if you don't point I don't know
where to run exactly that that's there
this chemistry is off the hook we gotta
get this on camera white guy number one
I have to I have a name damn it
you